It's very interesting because I have
worked with both chimpanzees and
dolphins and they're both incredibly
intelligent,
complex beings and it is difficult to
say who is more intelligent.
In fact,
when you get to the level of working
with an animal of that complexity,
it's very difficult to,
to rank them or to say who is more
intelligent than who,
uh,
it's easier to read chimpanzees because
they look like us.
They're our closest living relatives and
their body language and facial
expressions are very much like ours.
It's more difficult to read dolphins
because they don't have facial
expressions.
They don't look like us.
Um,
so,
so there is a difference in how we can
perceive their intelligence.
But I would have to say that having
worked with both,
they are a strikingly a bright.
Both of them.